[Music]
on this Monday night gaza's largest
hospital sends out an SOS the perilous
situation for hundreds of patients and
staff the people needing critical care
they are literally in in a very bad
situation where you slowly kill them
safe but separated from their parents
the plight of some pre-mature gazin
babies Deja Vu at 10 Downing Street why
former British Prime Minister David
Cameron is back in politics and
explosive prediction we don't feel great
signs in Iceland a volcano could erupt
at any
time global national with Donna Fen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with news about one of the
Canadians missing since the October 7th
attacks by Hamas on Israel it has now
been confirmed viven silver is dead it
was thought she'd been taken hostage but
a close friend now says forensic
identification confirms she was killed
during that attack on the kabut where
she lived silver originally from
Winnipeg was a renowned peace activist
she was dedicated to promoting shared
Society between Israelis and
Palestinians she was helping train gazan
residents on Business Development and
for years helped transport cancer
patients from Gaza to Israeli hospitals
this is her in
2017 we must change the Paradigm that we
have been taught for seven decades now
where we've been told that only war will
bring peace we don't believe that
anymore it's been proven that it's no TR
it's not true her last message to her
son was on October 7th from inside a
cupboard in her house where she was
hiding I love you she told her son
they're inside the house Vivien silver
was 74 years
old the World Health Organization says
gaza's largest hospital is no longer
functioning as a hospital and is nearly
a cemetery Israeli forces claim Hamas is
operating from beneath and beside gaza's
hospitals and that the command post is
under Al shifa hospital where soldiers
and tanks are closing in thousands of
people Sheltering there have now fled
but doctors say hundreds of patients
including dozens of babies are trapped
inside today the American President Joe
Biden said he has told the Israelis
hospitals must be
protected is my hope and expectation
that uh
there will be
uh
less intrusive action relative to the
hospital Israel continues to insist it
is not targeting civilians but gaza's
Health Ministry says 11,200 people have
been killed since October 7th more than
4,600 of them are children late today
the UN agency operating inside Gaza says
it has run out of fuel and will no
longer be able to receive Aid coming
through the Rafa cross Crossing into
Gaza a warning images in our stories are
disturbing Mike Armstrong begins our
coverage
tonight it is a staggering number
according to the UN from a population of
about 2.2 million 1.6 million gsin have
been forced out of their homes More than
70% 80-year-old Abu Shari Al Hayak says
his home was destroyed with everything
in it he left with only the clothes on
his
back for more than a week gsin have been
told to move South that Israeli Defense
Forces are mostly focused on Hamas
fighters in the North in Gaza
City but air strikes in the South
continue these are the injured in conice
rushed to hospital Monday
morning this man says he doesn't even
know what happened it was so
sudden now having so many people in the
south is causing more challeng Alles by
the day Aid is getting through but the
UN says only a fraction of what's needed
schools have become shelters but without
electricity and water un is struggling
to keep people from being exposed to
diseases caused by too many people
living in cramped quarters and the lack
of hygiene people in the shelters now
dream of taking a shower the mothers
dream of giving their children a
bath the Palestinian government Monday
rejected theidea of temporary camps for
displaced gazin the Prime Minister says
experience has shown temporary is
permanent he's also calling for Aid to
be aird dropped into
Gaza now according to the Hamas run
Health Ministry hospitals in Northern
Gaza are out of service surrounded by an
urban war zone and with access to
Medicine food and water
Limited at alifa hospital doctors say
they've lost several patients in
intensive care and just over the last 24
hours without fuel to run the incubators
three premature babies have died they
are literally in a very bad situation
where you slowly kill them unless
someone interferes to adjust or to
improve their situation I want you to
see this room now the IDF released a
series of videos shot it says at another
hospital just 2 kilm away it says it's
found evidence that hostages taken
October 7th were being kept in the
basement of Gaza City's rentis Hospital
toilets shower the IDF spokesman says
they found facilities were added to the
rooms there's a schedule for Hamas
fighters to watch hostages in shifts no
Reon fake curtains for shooting videos
of hostages and evidence of how they
were tied up a woman
clothes and a
rope a rope next to the legs now that
was the main IDF spokesman who gave that
tour Monday night he briefed the media
and said Hamas has effectively lost
control of Gaza that civilians are now
looting their bases and he said Hamas
fighters who are still in tunnels have a
choice they can either come out and
surrender or be eliminated that there is
no third option Donna Mike Armstrong in
Jerusalem thanks Mike some of gaza's
most vulnerable babies are being cared
for in hospitals that are not under
attack their mothers who were high risk
were allowed to seek treatment in
Palestinian hospitals in the West Bank
before October 7th and gave birth there
but some of the mothers have since had
to go back to Gaza and are not only
living under siege they don't know when
they'll see their babies again Danielle
Hamin has the
story there's a good chance some of
these babies would either be struggling
to survive today in a Gaza hospital
or already
dead if it hadn't been for complications
in the weeks before their birth before
October
7th Israel has allowed women women with
higher risk pregnancies to leave Gaza
for better
care and for most this place here is the
only
option here is nablas in the West Bank
100 kilm from Gaza on the other side of
Israel there are 20 babies in this
neonatal Intensive Care Unit two of them
should have been discharged a month ago
but there's nobody here to take them
home Muhammad and muayed were born at 29
weeks back in
August but life under Israeli occupation
meant their mother's permit to stay by
their side expired before they were
ready to be
discharged so she was forced to go back
home without them she's somewhere in
what's left of the jabalia refugee camp
and is now the one in danger not her
boys I
be safe be safety in Gaza that's fif a
social worker watching over the
twins it's the right of a mother to be
with her children she tells
us every day their mother sends messages
are they eating are they smiling are
they growing she's begging the hospital
not to discharge them until she can
return
the pain of not being able to hold her
babies is unbearable she
says then there's hanady she came from
Gaza to give birth only to lose her
child she now watches Gaza at a distance
praying she won't lose the rest of her
family as well her faith however is
unwavering this is what God wanted she
says dear this too was supposed to be
the joy of a lifetime she gave birth to
triplets but one died just as the war
started grief it seems is never too far
away I should have had my husband and my
mother by my side she tells
us away from their families and away
from the bombing for
now this will be
home Danielle Hamin Global News nablas
in the West
Bank the fighting inside Gaza is not the
only tension in the region the United
States conducted air strikes inside
Syria on Sunday night hitting what it
says are facilities used by Iran and its
proxies it's retaliation for recent
attacks on US forces in Iraq and Syria
by iran-backed militias dozens of US
soldiers have been injured Jackson prco
reports on the potential this has to
escalate inside Syria a quiet battle is
growing growing louder as the US carries
out more air strikes against what it
says are iran-backed militia groups
behind ongoing attacks on American
soldiers these attacks must
stop uh and if they don't stop then we
won't hesitate to do what's necessary
again to to protect our troops it's
direct Fallout from the conflict between
Israel and Hamas where Iran and its
proxies have threatened that Americans
will pay for what Israel does in
Iran is trying to poke and provoke the
United States but does not want a
broader War Iran recognizes its own
military weakness it recognizes that it
would be on the losing end of broader
War Iran insists the militant groups are
acting on their own accord the attacks
have only grown more frequent since the
first US air strikes in late October
more than 50 Americans have been injured
so far Iran acting in an escalatory
destabilizing way that under Minds uh
stability across the broader Middle East
is not in the interests of any other
responsible country the risk of a
miscalculation by either side is high
the US has dispatched two aircraft
carrier strike groups to the region as
deterrents repeated warnings to Iran
have been ignored if they continue to
move against those troops we will
respond and so the two sides are locked
in a tense standoff one that could lead
the US and Iran into direct cont fct
Jackson prosco Global News
Washington there's political Fallout
tonight over our reporting on foreign
interference by the Islamic Republic of
Iran on Canada globals the new reality
spoke to Iranian Canadians legal experts
and intelligence sources uncovering
evidence of hundreds of potentially
dangerous Iranian officials operating in
Canada [__] mahedi joins me now with
her exclusive reporting on this AAR
Donna the reaction to our investigation
has been pouring in some relieve the
details are finally coming out but if
you're not familiar with how dissidents
are being threatened here the
developments may come as a surprise that
reporting was shocking the leader of the
opposition has been vocal about getting
tough with the Iranian regime but even
he admits he had no idea how widespread
the problem is your
documentary made me realize how much
more uh brutal it is they will not be
prosecuted that's just a fact this
lawyer is identifying and investigating
an alarming number of regime insiders
operating in Canada and threatening
those who speak out against them we have
about 700 names right now um that are
either have temporary residents
permanent residents or citizenship that
are in Canada and that are somehow
regime Affiliates some of them have
citizenship they've had citizenship for
a long time and some of them had this
pre-planned already and they came to
Canada knowing that this is going to be
their Safe Haven they know where they
live in big mansions that they bought
from money they stole from poor poor
people in Iran to learn from your report
that it was
700 uh was staggering and it requires
immediate action to kick them out of
this country world-renowned human rights
activist Massi aliad has been the target
of multiple alleged plots against her
she is under constant FBI protection and
she has an unsettling message for
Canadians FBI warant me that Canada is
not safe that's heartbreaking it's
mind-blowing who would ever have thought
eight years ago that our allies would
think Canada is too dangerous a place to
go PV says the Islamic revolutionary
guard courp should be listed as a
terrorist entity immediately the
conservatives are also calling for more
sanctions and the creation of a foreign
agent registry to combat the growing
threat of Iranian interference on
Canadian soil as for how to do it we
reached out to the prime minister's
office and four cabinet ministers but
none were available for comment Donna
all right Nar M ahady
thanks there's a warning tonight about
an outbreak of salmonella spreading
across this country affecting young
children according to the public health
agency of Canada this strain is drug
resistant and may be difficult to treat
with antibiotics at least 40 cases have
been confirmed across six provinces
Manitoba Ontario Quebec New Brunswick
Nova Scotia and Prin Edward Island 43%
of the cases have involved children 5
years of age or under the outbreak is
being linked to Raw pet food and contact
with cattle Britain's former prime
minister bounces back coming up why
David Cameron has returned to the
political Arena plus trapped for a
second night the mission to save
construction workers stuck in a
tunnel what's old is New Again in the UK
former Prime Minister David Cameron has
been brought back to take on a top job
even though he's no longer an elected MP
Cameron is the new foreign secretary and
says he's accepted the role Because he
believes in public service he admits
it's not usual for a former leader to
return to politics the way he has
Crystal ganing looks at what Cameron's
stunning political comeback could mean
for the current
government it's back to the future in
London in 2016 David Cameron resigned as
prime minister leaving number 10 Downing
Street after his brexit referendum
morning now he's been handed a seat in
the House of Lords enabling him to serve
in Rishi Sun's cabinet Lord Cameron is
the new foreign secretary bringing in
David Cameron in many ways has gone
against the narrative that Rishi sunak
has been trying to establish in his
reboot of the government which is that
political leaders over the last 30 years
have somehow failed in the United
Kingdom that they've been not radical
that they've not tried to revise the
political and economic direction of the
United
Kingdom there's no doubt sunac is trying
to revise the direction of his
government the race Shuffle started with
the firing of Home Secretary suel
braan Braverman was a polarizing figure
accused of stoking tensions ahead of a
weekend protest in London but also for
her anti-immigration rhetoric using the
word hurricane on one occasion did
describe immigration to the UK I think
she needed to go for what she was been
saying recently her portfolio was handed
to James cleverly who says sunak gave
him clear instructions he wants us to uh
deliver on our promises to stop the
boats to protect the British people make
sure everybody feels secure in their
lives helping people feel secure
including the Prime Minister a man
chosen as the Leader by the conservative
party and set to face the public in a
general election next year I believe
Rishi sunak is a good Prime Minister
doing a difficult job at a hard time I
want to support him experts say Cameron
with his years of experience on the
world stage could give the Prime
Minister a little more time to focus on
domestic issues sunak has five priority
areas including growing the economy and
cutting weight times in the National
Health Service issues that are generally
top of mind for voters Crystal Gand in
Global News
London green goal ahead a new first ofit
kind holiday in
[Music]
Kenya streets were swamped in Western
Ireland as storm Debbie made landfall
along the Atlantic coast Vehicles were
partially submerged thousands of homes
lost power and Winds of over 120 km an
hour whipped through the country the
storm is expected to to move east across
Ireland Wind and Rain warnings are
already in force for Northern England
and Northeast
Scotland in Northern India a rescue
mission is underway to reach 40 workers
trapped underground after a tunnel it
was under construction collapsed during
a landslide on Sunday falling debris is
making the rescue mission more
challenging police say they've been in
touch with the workers who are safe and
are being supplied with oxygen and water
people in Kenya have been given a
holiday to help plant 100 million trees
the government is providing the
seedlings to be planted in designated
public areas everyone is being
encouraged to plant at least two the
goal is to seed at least 15 billion
trees over the next 10
years expected eruption next fears of a
volcano in Iceland has thousands of
people on
edge Iceland is used to Volcan anic
activity in fact its landscape and hot
springs are what draw tourists right now
though there's more activity than usual
the warning signs of a potential
volcanic eruption are everywhere people
in a coastal town near Iceland's Capital
have been ordered to leave there have
been thousands of Tremors recently
opening up large cracks in the earth
Redmond Shannon explains what all that
seismic activity could lead
to signs of What Lies Beneath steaming
cracks and crev has open up through the
Icelandic coastal town of grindvik
following weeks of incessant earthquakes
the town of less than 4,000 people was
evacuated quickly over the weekend there
are fears a volcanic eruption Could
Happen anywhere at any time the nearby
Blue Lagoon tourist hotspot has been
closed too authorities are now escorting
residents in one by one during a lull in
the Tremors we are waiting we are first
in line now to go into gind and you only
have a few minutes to grab things
activity from the nearby fogra dolls
fatle volcano has formed an underground
intrusion or stream of magma 15 kilm
long and right beside grindvik some of
the magma is now less than a kilometer
below the surface and the major worry
from a hazard and risk perspective is is
that the magma could come to the surface
and produce a Fisher eruption a Hawaiian
style lava producing volcanic eruption
that would happen if more magma feeds
the fissure fogar doll's fatle volcano
has been more active in recent years
locals hope this underground buildup
stops if it does that it will slowly
cool down and effectively freeze
solidify in place it's also possible
although less likely that magma comes to
the surface in or near water creating an
ash cloud similar to the huge Icelandic
eruption in 2010 that closed airspace on
and off for a month across Europe a
temporary inconvenience this event could
destroy a town we are in a in a big huge
um feeling of uh uncertainty and kind of
sadness and and and like despair there's
no planning anymore it's just we live
just from one day to another ultimately
Mother Nature will decide remond Chann
Global News
London that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna freezen tonight's your
Canada is these stunning iceburgs off
Fogo Island Newland and Labrador the
picture taken a few months ago we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at Global national.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye
n